let's see if we can calculate two point
nine one times three point two and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try it out on your own so the way I'm
going to think about it is two point
nine one two point nine one is the same
thing as 291 divided by ten and we know
that when you or not divided by ten
divided by 100 and we know that if you
divide something by 100 you're going to
move the decimal place two places to the
left one two and you would end up at two
point nine one it also makes sense if I
take two and I multiply it by a hundred
I'd get two hundred or if I take two
hundred and divided by a hundred I would
get two so it makes sense that two point
nine one is the same thing as two
hundred ninety-one divided by one
hundred similarly I can never say that
word 3.2 can be rewritten it's the same
thing as 32 divided by 32 divided by ten
now why is all of this interesting well
I could rewrite two point nine one times
three point two I can rewrite two point
nine one times three point two times
three point two as being the same thing
as instead of two point nine one I can
write 291 divided by 100 291 divided by
100 and then x times instead of writing
3.2 I could write 32 divided by 10 and
this can be rewritten as this is going
to be equal to 291 times 32 times 32
times 32 divided by a hundred divided by
100 I'm just reordering this divided by
100 divided by 10 divided by 10 or I
could rewrite this as I could rewrite
this this is equal to 291 times 32
times 32 if I divide by a hundred and
then I divide by 10 again I'm
essentially dividing by a thousand so
this part right over here
I could rewrite as dividing by a
thousand now why is this interesting
well I already know how to multiply 291
times 32 and then we know how to move
the decimal so that when we divide by a
thousand so let's calculate 291 times 32
let me write it right over here
291 times 32 times 32 notice this I've
just essentially rewritten this without
the decimals so this right over here but
of course these are different quantities
and this one is right over here to go
from this product to this product I have
to divide by a thousand but let's just
think about this we already know how to
compute this type of thing 2 times 1 is
2 2 times 9 is 18 carry the 1 2 times 2
is 4 plus 1 is 5 and now we can think
about the 3 3 times 1 I'll actually let
me throw a 0 here because this is now
this isn't a 3 this is now a 30s this is
in the tens place so that's why I put a
0 there so 30 times 1 is 30 that's why
we say 3 times 1 is 3 but it's notice
it's in the tens place right now and
then 3 times 7 so 3 times 9 is 27 carry
the 2 3 times 2 is 3 times 2 is 6 plus 2
is 8 and now we can add we can add and
we would get 2 8 plus 3 is 11 6 plus 3
is 13 and then you get 9 so you get nine
thousand three hundred and twelve so
this is going to be equal to nine
thousand three hundred and twelve
divided by 1,000 divided by 1000 and
what's this going to be equal to well if
we start with nine thousand three
hundred and twelve and I throw a decimal
there dividing by a thousand is
equivalent to moving the decimal over
three places to the left
so you divide by 10 divided by 100
divided by a thousand so that's going to
be nine point three one two so if you if
you divide by 1,000 you will get to nine
point three one two right this nine
point three let me write the decimal in
purple point three one nine point three
one two now there's something very
interesting here in our original when we
wrote the expression we had one two
three total numbers behind the decimal
and then over here we have one two three
total numbers to the right of the
decimal why is this well let's think
about it
we aree expressed this we express this
as 291 divided by hundred and this is 32
divided by 10 the hundred dividing by
100 and dividing by ten this essentially
accounts for these three decimal places
so we essentially get rid of those three
decimal places but then we have to
reintroduce those three decimal places
by dividing or we have to shift here we
shift the decimal and aggregate to the
right three times one two and then three
now in order to make sure we get the
right product we got to shift it back to
the left so we're shifting it one two
three so we went from this to this for
the whole product it was like
multiplying it was like dividing by it
was we essentially we essentially to go
from two go from here to here we
multiplied by 100 to go from here to
here we multiplied by 10 so in aggregate
we multiplied by a thousand and if you
think about both of these and so now we
have to divide by a thousand to get the
right value so that's why three decimal
places to the three numbers to three
spaces to the right of the decimal here
three digits to the right of the decimal
here